[Music]
and so what I want to do this morning is
give you a little perspective from
economics I spend most of my time
speaking and interacting with economists
right now is the American Economic
Association meeting that's going on I've
been to a whole set of other conferences
recently and you may not be surprised to
know that economists tend to take a more
pessimistic view on a lot of what's
happening it's often called the dismal
science inevitably I'm cast as the quote
techno optimist in these panels one of
my favorite sparring sparring partners
for this is a guy named Bob Gordon he
wrote a terrific book called the rise
and fall of American growth emphasized
on the fall and we go around we've been
friends for about 20 years we have
dinner together and we agree on a lot of
different things but we also disagree on
some things especially about the likely
trajectory of the future but one thing
we agree on is that Bob points out that
their history has been shaped by a
number of what he calls one-time
inventions things that could only be
invented once and then you just can't
progress further he gives some examples
for instance up penicillin or or air
conditioning once you get kind of
control 270 degrees or whatever your
comfort level is there isn't any real
benefit to being more precise than than
whatever the temperature you like or one
of his favorite examples actually is the
indoor plumbing and the flush toilet and
he talked about the tremendous and often
underappreciated benefits of simple but
important inventions like indoor
plumbing and as the economists feature
there's a real debate in the economics
profession about whether all the really
important inventions are behind us in
fact just two days ago a report came out
by Nick Bloom John van rhiannon at MIT
Michael Webb and Chad Jones basically
making the case that ideas are getting
harder and harder to find we're running
out of good ideas we're putting more and
more effort into trying to make tech
progress go forward and yet we're not
seeing a lot of results from I don't
take that view and I suspect many of you
in this room don't take that view I
think we're on the early stages of
probably the biggest one-time event to
use Bob Gordon's words the biggest
technological revolution which is around
artificial intelligence and some people
have called it our final invention if we
can solve intelligence we can solve so
many other problems and we are the
generation that I think is on the cusp
of seeing a lot of those hopes and
dreams come true but I'm not going to
give you the optimistic view today
because I don't think you guys need to
hear that I'm going to give you more of
the perspective some of the concerns
that economists have and share those
with you so you can hear about the
challenges because I'm not an
unconditional optimist I don't believe
that things will inevitably turn out
correctly along with Andy McAfee we've
been talking about a term we called
mindful optimism which is this idea that
we have have to take action to make sure
we get the right kind of future to occur
which i think is very much in the spirit
of the future of life Institute so
instead of talking about the great
things that a eye is doing let me talk
about some of the challenges and some of
the concerns and a good place to start
actually is with horses it turns out
that back in 1493 there were no horses
in the United States they weren't native
and Columbus brought them over on his
second voyage and the number of horses
that were employed grew steadily over
the next few centuries and in fact even
as the railroad the so called Iron Horse
became very important in the country the
number of horses a grew grew right
alongside it but as you probably know we
don't use horses a lot for
transportation anymore in fact peak
horse happened back in 1920 a little
less than 26 million horses were working
at that time and since then the number
of horses employed in the economy has
been falling it turns out that although
they were able to withstand wave after
wave of technological innovation better
chariots and stirrups and even the
railroad the automobile really and the
trucks and the associated technology has
really made it unnecessary to a plot use
a lot of horses in states if somebody
came to me and said hey you could have a
horse
Eric near for free and
could use it I don't know to go between
classes or something I would say that's
okay I just it wouldn't I wouldn't even
that zero price it wouldn't be worth it
for me so the question occurs number of
people have asked is will humans go the
way of courses in Andy and I wrote an
article with that title but we were
echoing this guy Vasily Leon - yup a
Nobel Prize winner who first asked the
question and he answered it with a
resounding yes
he thought using his input-output table
you can see behind there that as
technology progressed far enough the
need for human labour would shrink and
ultimately humans would go the way of
horses and would not be a necessary
input in the economy anymore and it
wasn't just him there a number of other
great economists who do litany of them
but but most notably perhaps is John
Maynard Keynes he wrote a terrific short
very readable article that I pointed to
called economic possibilities for our
grandchildren back in 1930 and he
predicted what life would be like in
2017 in Asilomar well maybe not the
Asilomar part but in 2017 and he
predicted that there would be less need
for human labour that we would get to
the point where what he called the
economic problem would be start becoming
solved ie basic goods and services we
could produce enough for everybody and
that was a good news he also thought
that there could be widespread is he
said technological unemployment as well
now I have to be clear many people's
like most economists don't agree with
these views and there are some strong
arguments why they are wrong and let me
lay those out but also let me show you
why some of those cultural arguments
aren't as strong either and ultimately
as I'll bring you to what my view is and
maybe see if you all agree this is a
topic will be discussing this afternoon
in a series of panels and discussions um
so of course horses have a fairly
limited set of capabilities humans can
do far more things and if you automate
the power of a car the muscle power you
still need somebody to control it to
drive it but increasingly we're
beginning to automate that as well so
the question is can this automation not
just of the horsepower but also the
brainpower progress and affect every
part of work so why not why wouldn't you
Monroe the way of horses well so there's
been some strong people taking exception
to this view one of the people who spoke
in the lagless about it we've had some
great conversations with him is mark
Andreasen and he makes a series of
arguments I think one of the most
compelling ones is just the argument
from histories that look we've had wave
after wave of technological innovation
and after each one there weren't fewer
jobs there were more jobs and the total
number of people working is greater now
admittedly the population is also
growing but we haven't had a
disappearance of jobs and a continent
number of economists are also making
this argument David autor colleague at
MIT has also made argument along these
lines the concern I had with this is
that just looking at history isn't
necessarily that reassuring at least not
to me I've no doubt that if there were a
talking course in 1900 you could point
around it and say that hey the number of
horses has been growing for all these
centuries
you know why worry about it it's going
to continue the way it has in the past
and of course that that horse would be
wrong because the technology evolved to
a point where it had enough capabilities
that the horse labor wasn't necessary so
by itself I think this history argument
is something that you know makes us
concern but I don't think it's very
definitive by itself another argument is
challenging what economists directively
call the lump of labor fallacy the idea
that there's just this fixed amount of
work to be done and that if you automate
some of it then that means there's less
for humans to do the reality is that
people can invent new things that they
want to work on in fact the National
Academy of Sciences made exactly this
argument
what is this twenty thirty years ago and
I can show it to you graphically a
little bit of economics 101 here for you
so there's something literally called
the law of demand and basically it says
that most goods and services have a
downward sloping demand curve which
means that if you lower the price you
increase the demand for them when things
get cheaper people tend to buy more of
it and depending on what the slope of
that demand is or more technically the
elasticity of demand you may actually
have more of an increase in demand than
you had a decline
it may end up spending more than you did
before when the price fault might seem a
little paradoxical but if you think
about there are many examples where the
price is fallen I don't know
jet travel and we spend more now that we
did fifty or a hundred years ago on some
of those goods so that's totally
possible but again this isn't completely
reassuring there are many other goods
where as we the price falls it becomes a
smaller smaller share of our input and
smaller share of our cost agriculture
and food is a prominent example in 1892
percent of the workforce 1942 percent
today about two percent of the workforce
we spend less and less because even
though the prices become much cheaper
there are limits to how much we can eat
he'll though I know many people are
trying to push those limits but but it
Altima today is not something that we
just buy more and more as it gets
cheaper more fundamentally the reason
that horse labor disappeared wasn't that
we became satiated with demand for
transportation I'm sure we travel far
more passenger miles now than we did
earlier the real reason was that there
are other technologies that allowed us
to do that and even if we had increased
demand it didn't mean that there'd be
more demand for the horses because other
technologies allowed us to do it which
brings us to another argument which is
this arguments that human needs written
here are two other very famous
economists who make this argument that
sure you satisfy one set of needs but
then there are other needs that become
emerge sources revellings a little play
on words saying that in fact it's not
necessity that they mother of invention
it's an invention that's the mother of
necessity that we will discover things
that we didn't even know we needed until
we start using them after a while
whether it's our iPhone or Facebook or
whatever and this is particularly
powerful and coupled with a fourth
argument that Jim Besson and others have
made again David otter which is that
humans are often indispensable for
certain types of production and in fact
the data shows that although ATMs have
automate a lot of work the number of
bank tellers went up from the 1990s
until 2009 although important footnote
Orca
PostScript to this is since then the
number of bank tellers has started
falling again so so if Jim were to
update his data he would not be able to
use this quote anymore but his
underlying point is an important one
which is that for many tasks if you
automate some of the steps they're still
an indispensable component that requires
human input humans are currently
uniquely good at creativity at
unstructured problem-solving another
category is emotional intelligence and
interpersonal skills many of these jobs
require a human touch a third category
is a lot of fine motor skills today
machines are not as good at adept at
walking up the stairs or picking up a
penny from the sidewalk and doing a lot
of fine motor tasks as humans are so to
the extent that a production process can
be automated partially but still has a
few components that requires humans
making parts of it cheaper actually
increases the demand for those humans
though the technology in more technical
terms is not a substitute but a
compliment for the human labor I think
this is probably the most powerful
argument over the next five to fifteen
to twenty years but you and you AI
researchers can help us understand we'll
have a panel this afternoon to discuss
further exactly where that boundary is
my experience leads me to never say
never that whenever there's a task that
I think can never be automated I end up
running it to somebody in a lab
somewhere that's working on using
technology to do exactly that task and
it's not hard for me to do a thought
experiment which Andy and I discussed in
our book we call it via the Android
experiment where imagine that you were
able to make a otamatone a machine that
had all the capabilities of a human then
what would happen to the economy well
then clearly this argument would you
know by definition no longer apply and I
guess it's a technological question as
to whether we could ever reach that
point but if we did then we would not
have this any demand for human labor
anymore on any of these dimensions well
that brings us to the fifth difference
and I think ultimately the most
important one of how humans are
different from horses and that's it we
can vote we we control the economic
system we get to run
how things are organized so we're not
just passive actors we can control
things and people can get angry if they
don't feel like they're getting their
fair share we certainly saw a lot of
that the past few years that this anger
can be channeled in lots of different
directions some of it constructive some
of it less constructive and I think that
if we don't take charge of how the
technology is affecting people if we
don't think about the effects and
institutions then other people will take
charge of that conversation and to the
extent that some people are being left
behind they will listen to other voices
so I think it's incumbent on us to try
to understand those flows let me briefly
describe a little bit about some of the
technological changes that are going on
well whether it's in manufacturing in
warehousing and logistics in services
and increasingly in the cognitive tasks
that would previously had been immune I
was on the AI 100 committee where we
talked about even a lot of skilled jobs
like pathologists being increasingly
affected by these technologies and
what's going on is that we're seeing
more and more parts of the economy being
affected it's showing up in employment
and it's showing up perhaps most
importantly it's not an employment but
in median income and this chart here the
red line is the real income adjusted for
inflation of what the median person and
median family in the United States can
buy and a similar pattern is holding
worldwide that's the person right as a
50th percentile half are above and half
are below and for most of history recent
economic history that was riding rising
right alongside productivity but for the
past 20 years or so it's become
decoupled and what we're seeing is that
the average person is not keeping up and
that reflects the fact that income has
become much more unequal the total pie
is growing reflected by the top blue
line but most more and more of that is
going to the top 1% to the top 1% of the
1% and the median person is being left
behind and that I think is a big part of
why we're seeing increasing anger in a
lot of countries it's a function of
three kinds of biased technical change
the first is skill-biased technical
change that the technology is
disproportionately automating
done by less skilled workers and more
skilled workers have done relatively
better a second kind of five secular
changes what we call capital buys
technical change
I think Jeff Sachs is going to talk a
bit about that this afternoon but you
see the orange line there is the share
of GDP that's gone to labor and recently
it started falling more and more steeply
and if anything this kind of
underestimate the effect on the average
worker this includes income going to
CEOs and sports Superstars and others
and certainly I would call something I
call superstar buys technical change
which is to share going to the very top
of the income distribution not just the
1% but here's the 1% of the 1% and that
is at an all-time high there are a
number of reasons for this but most
economists agree that the most important
single reason is the way technology is
being used if you have a good idea or
some talent or maybe some luck you can
take that and replicate it across
millions or billions of people and you
can become very very wealthy but if
you're in those categories where your
skills are being automated you're on the
other side of the coin so since our
conference in 2015 as max said the
conversation has really fundamentally
begun to change this is a relatively
minority small view back then but you're
hearing more and more people weigh in on
it Nobel Prize winners and and many
others are beginning to come around to
this view I think their own Asamoah is a
particularly prominent because he was a
major skeptic two years ago but to his
credit he went out and looked at the
data he did the research and now he has
turned around and said you know actually
this technology really is having a
second unemployment and Jeff is going to
talk about some of these issues later
this afternoon there's been a slew of
events none of these had happened before
2015 and so it's been a big change I
don't have time to go through all
thankfully max touched on a couple of
them but I would just note that Tom
Mitchell is Tom in the audience here
somewhere there is Tom and I actually
met in Puerto Rico at the last
conference somehow we hadn't crossed
paths before and so thank you to to yan
and the other organizers for getting us
together that led to us cooperating on
co-chairing this report sadly I'm not
allowed to tell you the contents of the
report it's embargoed
I think about five days from now but I
think you can get at some of the views
that will be coming out in that report
and many others I'm not going to go
through all of them but but these are
available and we're pulling together a
collection of them so you could find
them in one place let me finish by
talking about two kinds of optimism I
said I was an optimist Paul Romer talks
about some people being unconditional
optimists and he compares that to a
child waiting for a Christmas present
and you just know something's good is
going to happen if you just sit and wait
that's that's a great thing and that's
the nice kind of optimism to have but
that's not the kind of optimism that I
have unfortunately Andy and I and I hope
many of you are mindful optimist which
means that we are optimistic if we take
the right actions and it's not the child
waiting for Christmas with the child who
envisions save a tree house that you'd
like to have he doesn't just sit and
wait for it to happen he goes out and he
works on it he builds it he says hey
maybe if I get some wood some nails get
some friends to cooperate I can build a
fabulous tree house the best tree house
we've ever seen and that requires action
on our part so let me encourage all of
you to take up a challenge a grand
challenge similar to the technological
Grand Challenges that led to the
self-driving car and robotics but now
it's an economic grand challenge and
that's to understand that these
technologies are going to continue
progress and thank god that's going to
give us more and more tools to change
the world but we need to make sure that
our skills our organizations our
institutions
keep up and that won't happen
automatically in fact I think we are
falling further and further behind that
gap is growing one of the reasons we're
seeing median income stagnating despite
more and more technological capabilities
is that we have not been reinventing our
economy we the way we need to and that's
an area that requires real focus at the
initiative on the digital economy we've
watched it launch an inclusive
innovation challenge to try to encourage
people to work on this particular
problem and create prosperity for the
many not just a few but they're a whole
set of policy levers and my last slide
I'm sorry is that there's a whole set of
parameters we can work on we're going to
talk about that from three to six this
afternoon a bunch of choices that we can
make
that will transform the economy and by
fiddling with these the right way I'm
extremely confident that we can not only
make the pie bigger and create more
prosperity but create shared prosperity
but ultimately it's not going to happen
unless we actively work on this question
so again thank you very much for
organizing this conference and I look
forward to getting to work on exactly
these problems Thanks so one thing you
didn't mention is 50 percent deflation
rate inherent in information technology
so when this middle worker whose wages
are supposedly stagnant was a 300 all
smartphone she's getting yeah trillion
dollars of computation SiC in 1965 and
say well she can't really benefit from
all the computation directly but she's
getting millions of dollars of free
services of pre encyclopedia etcetera so
then the challenge is ok it's true for
this really interesting world of
information products but you can't eat
information technology can't live in it
you can't we're in it the point I make
is that all that's going to change we're
going to print out clothing in the 2020s
or 3d printers and built a manufactured
modules you can snap together and build
a house inexpensively we're going to
have vertical agriculture which will
automate food production make it very
inexpensive so the value of a dollar is
actually going up but we don't see that
because we take the these gains in the
numerator and the denominator so it's a
where's the productivity gains I think
this is a very important point and sadly
I had to cut a whole section of slides
addressing this exactly but since you
asked the question gives me a chance to
address it you're absolutely right
GDP mistress misses a big part of the
value of the economy and I've done a lot
of research on the value of pre goods
those goods that you just listed I have
a couple of papers estimating the
contribution it's hundreds of billions
of dollars it's quite significant and it
means we were under estimating growth to
some extent that's important however
what Bob Gordon quickly points out to me
is we were missing
a lot of benefits in the past as well
that the flush toilet and others had
significant benefits penicillin that
were counted in the GDP as well and it's
not at all clear that the rate that we
were missing stuff has increased in fact
some people chassis verse and others
argue that if anything that net
effectiveness measurement is going the
other way it's a debatable question I
think it's one that we need to look into
further
but the second part of your point I
think is the one we have to work on
which is that these technologies can
allow us to do to bring the information
revolution to other parts of the economy
and it may well be that the real reason
we're not seeing the benefits is that
they're still somewhere in the future
I don't think that automatically means
they're going to be widely shared that's
that we have to work on but it's the
right way to think about it eliezer
yudkowsky so indeed by automation has
always been ongoing but like we've seen
recently a like drop in labor force
participation so there are various
restoring forces that cause employment
like people getting jobs again and if
we're seeing labor force participation
drops we could say that automation has
become more sphere we could say that
something is like blocking the restoring
forces like implicit marginal tax rates
or making the high school dropout do
paperwork can you address like yeah how
we know that's automation and not the
restoring forces that are getting
blocked there are definitely a lot of
factors and I've emphasized just the
role of Technology it's certainly
important that there are other factors
whether it's tax policy deregulation
globalization I did a slide very quickly
to read through all of them I think most
economists feel that technological
change has been the biggest fact in the
biggest factor in the change in labor
force participation recently but I do
think if we change some of those other
policies we can lean against the wind
and instead of exacerbating that we can
mitigate it and even perhaps reverse it
there are a whole set of factors at work
but the role of technology Larry Katz
had a quote up there was far bigger than
trade deregulation or any of the other
factors involved but but this is
something that we will try it out try to
sort through the
importance of each of them ultimately
it's a good thing that there are other
factors that are important as well it
means that we have more policy levers
that we can try to counteract some of
the effects the technology has had
[Music]